hello and welcome to another video today
we're going to talk about an anime
series called zetman which is action
drama anime without any further ado
let's dive right in the series starts
with a brief introduction of how
monsters known as players came into
being and how they managed to merge with
society kanzaki a man working in an
underground laboratory takes away a baby
sleeping in a capsule while an old man
named mitsugai tries to stop him but
it's all in vain ten years later a man
and woman are walking down the street
the woman tells the man she's afraid of
the serial killer so she wants to go
home the man however doesn't see the
severity of the situation and goes on to
say that it would be cool if they happen
to witness a serial killing unbeknownst
to him though the serial killer passes
by and kills the man without anyone
noticing leaving the woman screaming in
terror the investigators come and one of
them wonders how this could happen in
broad daylight while some mysterious men
pass by in a black car an old man
sitting in that black car says that he
must find a child but one of them
wonders if he's alive or not the man
grins and says that he's an immortal
devil the scene switches to the grown-up
baby named jin who's about to leave but
his grandfather kanzaki stops him saying
that he forgot something and gives him
his cell he finds a woman named argemi
in trouble and saves her by beating up
the attacking thugs for ten thousand yen
his childhood friend gulga and gonohar
show up and gorga drags him away saying
that justice doesn't need rewards
jin shows them the mark on his hand
called angel's ring but tells them to
keep it a secret meanwhile a mysterious
man named seiji makes a deal with the
same player who killed the man before
jin runs into argemi again and gets his
10 000 yen and returns home to find
everyone dead he doesn't understand
what's going on and tries to take his
dead grandfather to a doctor to find out
what's wrong with him but he ends up
going to argue me as the doctor refused
to check him they took kanzaki to the
hospital but he was already dead too
argemi took gin to her house they bathed
together and jin asks her what being
dead means and says he wants to see his
grandfather again and then breaks down
in tears the next day they go shopping
but are attacked by the same player
arkemi tries to protect him but ends up
getting slashed in the face which
infuriates jin he activates his power of
zet takes out the player with one blow
and ends up falling unconscious later he
wakes up in a hospital with an
investigator by his side he gives him
some words of advice and jin asks him
what hope means he takes jin to argemi's
room and tells him that she is hope and
they share a hug a few years later seiji
is featured talking with another
rampaging player with fire abilities in
downtown a fight breaks out between two
homeless guys gonoha who's distributing
food with her mother tries to stop the
fight just when she's about to get
attacked a teenager steps in and stops
the fight the teenager turned out to be
none other than jin himself he walks
away and goes to akemi who's now working
on a store
in the underground laboratory mitsuga is
working to create another zed like jin
that fails to do so even with ganzaki's
data in a party arranged by amagi
corporation the adult kurga makes a
statement to become an ally of justice
like alphas who's a superhero in anime
he goes out and joins his crew to locate
the arsonist meanwhile jin walks out
from home because of itching in his
senses he discovers the arsonist in a
building and fights with him the
arsonist gives jin a hard time meanwhile
gaugart reaches the building with his
crew he meets with jin and uses his fire
extinguishing spray on the surrounding
fire they discover a family stuck in the
building jyn throws the family with the
bed down to save them gulga escapes the
scene and unintentionally gains the
credit for saving the family jin
struggles against the arsonist and ends
up activating his zet powers he
transforms into a monster and kills him
with one punch jin escapes the building
and falls unconscious gonohar takes him
to the hospital where her grandfather
mitsugai identifies him as the child
taken by kanzaki jin wakes up and finds
his foster mother held by a player jin
transforms enraged to save his mother
while mitsugai and other scientists keep
track of his transformation from outside
he kills the other player with a single
punch as usual for the first time in his
life jin witnesses his set form in a
rage he breaks the glass of the
laboratory he's shocked to find that his
mother has turned into a player and he
must kill her as zep form can't stand a
berserk living player in the
surroundings the armed men of mitsugai
shoot his mother as he fails to kill her
jin breaks into tears while returning to
his human form
jin wakes up in a locked cell mitsugai
gives him a dose of medicine and takes
him to an abandoned underground facility
he explains to him that they made him
and ganzaki was his father mitsugai
developed some monsters to make money
but these monsters developed
intelligence and broke out into human
society to atone for his sin they made a
powerful monster with the power of ring
of exposure that can reveal a monster
disguised in human flesh and that
monster is none other than jin ganzaki
just when they're leaving the ring of
exposure on the wall begins to resonate
with the ring on the left arm of jin
indicating that they're connected
mitsugai takes him to the store where
argemi is working perfectly fine he
breaks it to jin that the argemi he saw
in the laboratory was a monster made by
them to test his set transformation
level jin decides to meet her but
mitsugai stops him he tells him from now
on he should maintain distance from his
beloved ones because if he lives with
her other players will target her upon
reaching the household of armage he asks
jin to join him so that he can stop the
players from wreaking havoc jin accepts
his offer as the old guy promised to
heal off the scar on her foster mother's
face he tells him about the final form
of zet which is red and more powerful
than all the players seiji is found
wandering near the abandoned facility he
discovers a broken part of the ring of
exposure to which he smiles and walks
out two years later the investigators
discover another case of a killing this
time the victim has turned into sand
downtown several players are killing
humans a red-haired girl unintentionally
witnesses the whole thing she leaves her
case and runs for her life the players
search for her the girl hides in a small
house while the men from amagi
corporation watch the whole thing from
cameras we see a flashback where
mitsugai conducts various tests on gym
to transform him into zet but it's all
in vain they developed a gum called
activation gum to kickstart his
transformation but still the results
weren't good on the other hand gonoha
and her mother continued to distribute
food to homeless people in the armage
corporation building the teammates of
gulgar present him with new gadgets
capable of helping in various situations
on his way back his father's secretary
encourages him to continue his work of
justice he tells him about his secret
project of creating a powerful suit with
the military technology of the company
for him to continue his work for justice
konoha comes across jyn again she tries
to talk to him but he tells her to stay
away from him after coming home jyn
finds the red-haired girl hiding in his
house he tells her to get out but she
explains about the dangerous man outside
looking for her he gives her food to
which she compliments him a lot she
tries to ask him more but jin ignores
her suddenly he gets a stench and heads
out while telling her to stay in the
house she chases him after and finds her
lost bag as she grabs her bag the man
from before appears behind her and holds
her down she tries to fight back but
it's all in vain jin intervenes and
demands 10 000 yen for saving her to
which she happily agrees but he
brilliantly counters and attacks him
back the man reverts to his original
player form and jin ends up taking the
activation gum despite activating some
power the man beats him up the
subordinates of mitsugai shoot the
captured girl with a sleeping drug as
the player drives jin to death he
miraculously transforms into white zed a
new form and kills him mitsugai is
thrilled to see this transformation of
zet however things aren't normal yet
because the player's main body has
escaped the man dressed in a white suit
known as sweeper kills the player's main
body because of a violation of their
rules the man belongs to avol an
organization consisting of elite players
jin reverts to his human form and takes
the girl home when he reaches home jin
stabbed by the sweeper amidst a guy
shocked to find the existence of the
sweeper seiji intervenes and tells the
sweeper to stop because their boss will
be angry over his death jin asks
questions but he tells him they're a
secret seiji tells him that he's waiting
for his final transformation and then
leaves mitsugai and his men reach the
destination and are relieved to find jin
alive even after encounting the sweeper
on the other hand gulgar visits the
secret lab with his father's secretary
he presents them with a strength suit
developed following the superhero alpha
suit guard points out the mistakes in
the design and asks them to modify it
gulga thanks the secretary for his
continuous support on his way back home
he encounters a man who claims to be his
fan he tells him that he'll support
gulga if he manages to clear some tests
for a hero he shows him a video of
gonoha drowning in the school swim pool
while her teacher stands there in the
corner he also shows him three girls in
danger who also happen to be his fans he
asks him who he'd protect as a test kuga
rushes to the school of gonoha only to
find her safe taking swimming classes
with a teacher the scene shifts to a bar
where the man's giving money to konoha's
teacher for her fake actions the bart
turns out to be the base of evol and all
people in the bar are elite players the
next morning gulgar sees the news about
the murder of three high school girls
just like the man told him he receives a
call from that man who tells him that he
failed the test google asks his
secretary to locate this man to stop him
from future murders he receives a call
from gonoha she invites him in her plan
of meeting jin but gulga harshly refuses
next we see the same two players from
earlier who escaped from the battle with
jim
soon they're interrupted by seiji who
compels them to kill jin as they despise
him he also assures them that he'll stop
the sweeper from interfering to which
they happily agree the scene shifts to
jinn who walks out with the redhead girl
to buy food he comes across gonoha who's
surprised to see jin with a girl jin
leaves after having a short conversation
with konoha suddenly jin comes back to
his sixth sense only to find the players
who kidnapped gonoha and her friend the
man reversed to his player form and
attacks him jin realizes that he's left
the activation gum at home much to his
dismay on the other hand kuga receives a
call from konoha asking for help gulga
equips the modified suit and leaves to
save her jin sustained heavy damage
during his fight with the player as he
couldn't transform mitsugai and his team
continue to track his stats for zet's
transformation jin gathers his strength
and lands a solid punch on the player
but he turns out unharmed from the smoke
the other player tortures gonohar to the
point she ends up wetting herself jin
leaves to save guanoha after dealing
some damage to the player jin enters an
abandoned building and saves gonoha but
the hiding player attacks him and
pierces his weapon-like sharp limb
through him just when things are looking
very grim gurgaon makes an appearance in
alpha's suit and kills the player with
his beam gun the experience is another
challenging choice as his helicarrier
can only lift two people while there are
three injured people including jim he
carries konoha and her friend to the
helicarrier and sends them off upon
constant pressure from jin guga explains
to him that he's become alphas to serve
justice jin leaves to kill the remaining
player however he struggles to stand
because of his severe injuries the
homeless guys gather to fight the player
gulgar steps in to save them and on the
other hand seiji makes an appearance and
throws jin into a room he breaks it to
him that he knows all about him and now
he's trying to transform into zet by
damaging seiji takes out a stake made
from the fragments of ring of exposure
taken from the abandoned facility he
engraves the stake in the chest of jinn
making him scream in endless pain soon
after a spark of energy emerges and
jin's ring on his left hand begins to
glow transforming him into zet first his
body turns black and white which is an
indication of the third form but the
transformation doesn't stop there after
a massive explosion zett achieves his
final form which is red and black the
impact of transformation destroys the
whole building and after the smoke
screen set in his marvelous final form
surfaces sage is delighted to see him in
his final stage
what will be zett's course of action in
his final form continue the anime from
episode 7 to discover more about the
fate of zett and his beloved ones
if you made it to this point congrats
for having the attention span higher
than the average person nowadays i'd
like to thank you for being awesome and
sticking to this point so yeah thank you
very much if you've already liked and
subscribed know that we appreciate it
and we'll always try to entertain you
with that being said see you next time